the try guys were four guys that did uh
viral videos uh for BuzzFeed where they
would try to do things they uh would
have all these videos and then they got
bigger than BuzzFeed they left BuzzFeed
took the name the IP all of that stuff
and made their own channel they're
beloved on the internet they're like
sort of quirky
um they are
just well really well liked and there's
a guy on there named Ned and Ned was
married to this woman who he also made
content with it was super well loved and
then he cheated on his wife with a
producer of the try guys
and they've had to fire him from the try
guys it's really like imploded them
and it's big on the internet did they
fire him for sleeping with the producer
yeah
why because it was like he was her boss
it was like an inner he says it's
consensual like he says this it's a
consensual relationship that I made a
mistake on he's trying to make a new
video let me try to sleep with my
producer yeah exactly the crazy thing is
it blew up internally first and they
were like oh you can't be banging like
our producers like you gotta go yeah and
then he was caught in public at a bar
with the girl yeah someone took a
picture like Yo this is the guy that
makes wife content and then post it
online is like why is he kissing this
girl and then he makes wife content like
he's like basically monopolized his
relationship or like as like commodifies
relationship where he's like I'm the
wife guy and I love my wife and me and
her we do tick tocks together and this
is my wife and like our relationship
every single time yep every single month
yeah that's very fair to say
The Harder They Fall bro it's like what
that Adam Levine [ __ ] thing there was
that picture that came out of him it was
real long time ago but he was at some
concert he had a blue shirt on that just
said feminist on it yeah and it's just
like every single time the more perfect
they seem the more piece of [ __ ] they
are and people are so afraid for some
reason to just be a piece of [ __ ] openly
when we like pieces of [ __ ] yeah
normal they make us feel okay that's why
I love Michael Blackson he's like bro I
I get I get girlfriends sometimes yeah
me and my wife we have a thing we're
cool like that's what he does yeah he's
just like super open about it he's like
I don't have to hide this this is what
I'm doing yeah God Bless but it is it is
wild that he I don't know I'm like
sleeping with your producer yeah I get
that's worth getting him out of there
why why because she works
it's a thing no no I don't subscribe to
this I don't like this idea that humans
are not capable of making decisions and
I think that's what that is I understand
you have to like set up rules to protect
all these people because there are these
Bad actors that are willing to take
advantage of the people that are working
for them but I also think that you can
develop a consensual and loving
relationship with someone you work for
or somebody that works for you so it
sucks that
we're basically like eliminating those
relationships and I bet if you look back
like in time the majority of [ __ ]
human beings have probably met their
wife by working with them it's a huge
percentage huge like huge conflict of
interest don't you think it kind of
throws the vibe off a little there's
also like declaration yeah you're both
passionate about the same thing you both
have all that in common you're spending
so much time together you're building
like a real Foundation of relationship
based on like Mutual interests but if
their brand is built on being good guys
and you're out here sleeping with
someone we're not talking about that
we're talking about what we're talking
about though okay Central relationships
in the workplace if you go to HR you
have to close their place there's no
question if you go to HR and disclose
the relationship then you're fine yeah
what Mark is saying I think you were
saying is that in the relationship
itself is null and void because of the
power Dynamic that exists no no like
they can have a consensual relationship
but I get why they would want to either
change her around or if he was not
disclosing the relationship terminated
his employment yeah so oh you're what
you're saying is he's being sneaky
because he's cheating on his wife so he
can't say I'm in a relationship with the
producer and so when they go to HR so
then they find out and then I get why
they're determining his employment
because he's not disclosing yeah yeah I
mean like he's a hypocrite for being
wife guy while also doing it but at the
same time it's like it's like one of
those people like find their [ __ ]
shtick and now they're like a prisoner
of the shtick like he's not white guy as
much as he like he's not in love with
his relationship as much as he is in
love with making money being a life guy
being in love with himself and it's also
coming on the girls part it's like yo
you know this guy's got a wife yeah you
see her every week like she comes in
they would make content together that's
his question he's been fired obviously
power dynamics many things happen uh and
the reason he's fired there's not word
if the as of from what I know at this
exact moment if the producer has been
fired also she shouldn't go far yeah why
why wait why not she also broke the
rules right no only the yeah she's a
senior person the senior person it
breaks the rule interesting yeah because
the power Dynamic what if he pressured
her to sleep with him consent can exist
with power vacuums you gotta suck my
dick I think that's a bit black and
white isn't it consent cannot exist
without a with the power Dynamic again I
mean well there's always a power Dynamic
that's the other thing it's like even if
they won't work for somebody there's
always going to be a paradigm yeah it
exists so then disclose it yeah I mean
if we really want to talk about it like
the power Dynamic is is wildly skewed
towards women like we cannot have sex
with them unless they say okay it is
illegal that's not 50 50. that is zero
one hundred if a woman marries a rich
guy if a rich guy dates a beautiful girl
is he taking advantage of the power
Dynamic the fact that I'm a rich 100
yeah to take advantage of the access to
all the things he different had like of
course but we're saying in the workplace
is different I was in the workplace
somebody can hold your job over you and
that's the that's fine that's [ __ ] up
and there's and they're guys that do
that and that's [ __ ] up and that's
horrible and I think the real mess up
here is when women and this is the
Weinstein [ __ ] it's like when women
complain about this and they cover it up
and protect the person in power like
that these people right here that are
protecting the guy who's [ __ ] up
destroys consensual work relationships
because now that woman has no recourse
to keep her job and protect herself and
then every other girl in the company is
like I better not say or else I'm gonna
get fired but if every time the woman
complained they just fired the [ __ ]
boss who broke the goddamn rules or the
map consensual sorry yeah or it could
happen the other yeah go ahead but we
can have essential work relationships
because any time it was uncomfortable or
do cross the line or a woman crossed the
line and that was complained about and
that person got fired Everybody's Free
but now we have to build all these
[ __ ] rules because these [ __ ] in
HR and like the the shareholders and
these [ __ ] board meetings are going
hey we can't get rid of this [ __ ] CEO
we can't really get a Weinstein he's
really good at picking movies so protect
that [ __ ] even though he's a
rapist it's like all those people should
be going down with Weinstein and with
the 100 100 bro 100 the girl says hey
this guy [ __ ] raped me and you go
well don't you want to work in Hollywood
blah blah blah you are completely oh
that rapist the guy that the girl went
to yeah
the girls shouldn't no no no no no no
girls who kept quiet no no no no no no
people are covered up I hit the women
yeah yeah or the women who quiet the
women but the ones who protect the
[ __ ] rapists yeah yeah and I'm like
that whole it's like the rapists and the
protectors are the people that make it
so uncomfortable for the I guess the
women or even the men that are uh is
subordinate is that the word yeah yeah
like it's you're completely powerless in
that situation and now you can't even
raise within the company because now
you're terrified these people don't have
your if you're comfortable being vocal
there's not the power Dynamic being
exploited nearly as much thank you for
articulating that but that's if the
systems that you're talking to are even
willing to hear a complaint to his point
that's the problem yeah the problem is
that because like he said earlier most
not most a huge percentage of
relationships begin in the workplace a
lot of those relationships before this a
lot of those relationships there was a
power Dynamic like just in the sense
that one person was a boss and one
person was not a boss so if we have an
environment where this subordinate
person is comfortable being vocal if
they're if this person is making them
uncomfortable then that [ __ ] is all we
can just have one do you feel like most
workplaces probably favor a really
talented powerful racist they do and
that's why you should punish the people
will help cover up for that guy that
powerful man or woman that person that
helps cover up should be just as cult
but you're saying it's like oh it's
those companies that [ __ ] it up forever
I'm like I think that's probably just
most organizations it's just people that
cover it up that [ __ ] it up to be honest
with you I think the system that's set
up
is by the shareholders or by the
protectors it's like why don't we just
make it so nobody can [ __ ] anybody here
and then our CEO won't [ __ ] it up by
screwing some of the employees and then
pissing them off so we're just going to
make this blanket rule to protect our
real Golden Goose which is a CO maybe
not his secretary if it does both
they're like yeah but yeah it's probably
just an easier way to legislate I don't
have to get into the nitty-gritty and
waste [ __ ] time with who's writing
who's wrong you didn't disclose you're
fired yeah